really go for some coffee you want some
coffee
let's get some coffee so ah I didn't
think I'd be doing this one detective
Pikachu
yeah I hadn't planned to see this I did
like it's not it's not like a sonic the
hedgecock
head good uh words it's not like a Sonic
the Hedgehog thing where I saw the
trailer I was like oh my god it was it's
just a case of pokemons not part of my
fandom like I I played I don't know
maybe five hours worth of pokemon yellow
like way back in the late 90s I never
watched the cartoon I never really got
into anything it's like I know what it
is I know through osmosis some of the
better-known Pokemon of course I know
who Pikachu is but like for the most
part it's just it's just never been a
phantom that I've gotten into so I had
no particular oh yeah I had no dog in
this race now the funny thing was I
asked my because it was playing at the
theater I just asked well kind of
offhandedly if my daughter had any
interested in seeing it I didn't think
she would because she's not really into
Pokemon either but you didn't want to
see it because she thinks Pikachu is
cute and there are a few things that
will drive my daughter's decision making
then cute animals so I've now seen
detective Pikachu and you consider this
an outsider's perspective again I'm not
coming in completely cold I'm too
immersing geek culture to like do not at
least have a base level knowledge on on
Pokemon but like I'm not steeped in it
so that's the opinion I'm coming at this
with em cuz considering that I am
neither the target demographic in terms
of age nor in terms of interest cuz I
never got into this fandom what bad I
don't want to oversell it by any means
by default is probably the best video
game addict
a Shinto film so far not video game
adaptation period that goes to
Castlevania right now but as far as film
definitely theme theatrically released
film yeah easily the best one so it's it
is interestingly paced it's actually got
a bit of a mystery it's got twists it's
got turns the dynamic between the lead
characters is pretty good
like the you pikachu's gets Pikachu gets
all the press because you know it's
riled Bret Ryan Reynolds basically doing
family-friendly Deadpool I mean that
that's pretty much how he's performing
it but actually the the actual lead
justice Smith who have only seen that a
couple of things I watch like two
episodes of the get-down
and it just didn't grab me and stick to
it after that and I did not like him at
all in Jurassic world fallen Kingdom but
he was actually really good in this
because it's not easy to be the straight
man especially in a world this nuts so
he did a pretty good job and actually
got a lot of emotional truth out of the
things he was asked to do because
despite being the straight man he's
carrying most of the emotional weight of
this story because it opens with him you
know finding out that his father's dead
and he plays that pretty straight it's
not played lightly the emotional weight
is given real and like I didn't tear up
at any moments but I did feel like the
biggest hint of a lump at a few points
of my own I wasn't expecting to feel
again I don't want to overemphasize it
wasn't like oh right nard like no just a
little little twinge but more than I was
expecting from a movie like this
certainly he's also got a really good
dynamic with Ryan Reynolds as Pikachu
and he does a really good job selling
the performance with this thing that was
not actually there some actors do not
know how to convincingly interact with
something that was obviously gonna be
added in later in post he does a really
good job at it overall I've actually
just flat out really impressed with him
as an actor he has to do a lot in this
and he has to make it look pretty
effortless so he's really good
Ryan Reynolds is really good there's a
few other supporting characters who are
fine Bill Nighy ease I mean Bill Nighy
can't be bad but he's fine
Ken Watanabe is fine most of the other
supporting characters are a bit hammy
so like for instance there's the female
lead who is uh who's a reporter she has
a side duck so I remember thinking when
she was on screen that her performance
brought to mind like Disney made-for-tv
now don't get me wrong she would have
been the highlight in a Disney
made-for-tv movie but to see that kind
of performance put in a theatrically
released film is a little bit like uh
and a fair amount of the supporting
characters kind of fall under that that
kind of heading there just a little bit
there cartoonish is too strong a word
they're not quite there but especially
consumer considering what a naturalistic
performance justice Smith is bringing
the fact that these other characters
just aren't it doesn't it could have
made it feel like he was out of place
instead it makes it feel like they're
all out of place cuz he does it so well
it's actually kind of fascinating now
that I stop and think about it um as far
as the mystery aspect to it cuz they
it's it's it's sort of a baby's first
noir kind of a plot and if you're
familiar with these kinds of stories at
all if you're familiar with the tropes
at all you are gonna figure out if not
exactly how everything goes down you are
gonna figure out who the villain is of
this before a tee dang quick but I'm not
necessarily gonna knock the film on it
that's where one of those that's becomes
one of those things where like it
doesn't work for me but I'm also not the
target demographic age wise because you
know I've seen a lot of stuff like this
in terms of the general tone and feel
and vibe of the thing so of course I'm
gonna suss this out immediately now the
target the primary target demographic of
younger kids they haven't seen
much so they are less likely to make
those leaps and make the guesses so I
mean I I try and I try and balance it
really carefully I don't
as a rule of thumb I don't like to give
a pass on the basis of well it's for
kids it doesn't have to be smart but
like no it should be but I do try and
make allowances for basically everybody
has their first cliche at some point so
when a piece of media is aimed at an age
group that it's not unreasonable to
assume that they haven't encountered
this cliche before I try not to harp on
it too much I'll still point out that
it's a cliche but I'm not gonna ding the
film as much as I would if it was in
something being presented and intended
for adults which I mean I don't want to
say this isn't for adults I don't want
to make it seem like those who leave the
kids here go see something else like
it's not like that and I think adults
who who like Pokemon are gotta find
plenty of like here the visualization of
the Pokemon themselves is actually
really well done because basically
they're all true to the original design
it's just they've been realistically
textured but Pikachu it looks like
Pikachu he's just got you know fine fur
a Bulbasaur looks like a Bulbasaur it's
just got you know that that sort of
slightly slimy texture going on the skin
and stuff like that um the it's not
photo real but then again it really
shouldn't because to try and do it more
photorealistic would have been - Wow to
make the mistake that Sonic the Hedgehog
made and like go and scrap a classic
design that works for a reason so you
know they didn't do that and it's uh
it's just nice it's a nice Pleasant
thing I think if you yourself have
Pokemon nostalgia you'll probably get
some enjoyment out of this just don't
expect to be surprised by the plot if
you have young kids if they like Pokemon
they'll probably enjoy this quite a bit
if you have a kid like my kid who just
likes really cute animals or animal-like
creatures yeah she actually enjoyed this
quite a bit again mainly on the basis of
cuteness
she loved Pikachu
she'd like the other ones pretty well
but that I mean that was that was her
jam she was all over Pikachu she thought
he was the cutest thing ever and yeah
that's about it like I I didn't know if
this was gonna hurt or not I didn't know
if this was just gonna be a string of
inside jokes and references that I
wasn't gonna get but worked pretty well
and I actually got a got to give some
props to the fact that they didn't go
with what would have been the obvious
just standard Pokemon plot you know of
the trainer who has to go through the
gyms and defeat the team whatever this
week thing like they scrap that and I
know detective Pikachu like is a
pre-existing game I don't know if this
actually imports the story directly I
never played detective Pikachu but I
think this was a much better call than
doing what would have been the obvious
thing which is basically the kind of
story that the cartoon did forever so I
think this works much better in a film
setting it was a really strong way to
introduce Pokemon in a live-action
setting and just to have the creatures
just be there I mean and you know every
now and then they get identified what
they can do get singled out but it's not
this big long protracted night we must
explain this and this like no they're
just around this is just the world
they're just here like you like you see
a flock of birds and like oh let's
Pidgey Pidgey oh I don't know letting my
ignorance show now I'll wrap it up there
detective Pikachu you've seen it what
did you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there's all
sorts of stuff down there there's merch
and there's links out there stuff that I
do and there's the patreon which if you
go check that out there are rewards
involved gets you access to the discord
you can get you get to vote on topics
you can get your name on the credits and
so much more depending on what you go
for check it out or also don't you don't
have to because at the end of the day
folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time be a true
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]